♪ ♪
>> WE ARE FACING ALARMING TRENDS
IN THE RISE IN VOLUMES OF PEOPLE
ILLEGALLY CROSSING THE SOUTHWEST
BORDER AND ARRIVING AT PORTS OF
ENTRY'S.
THIS INCREASED FLOW PRESENTS
CURRENTLY OUR HIGHEST LEVELS IN
OVER A DECADE, THE BOTH A BORDER
SECURITY AND HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS.
REGARDLESS OF ANYONE'S PREFERRED
POLICY OUTCOME, THE STATUS WERE
ALWAYS ON ACCEPTABLE.
>> Laura: IN THIS FISCAL YEAR
SO FAR, THERE HAVE BEEN MORE
THAN 300% INCREASE IN THE NUMBER
OF FAMILY UNITS, PEOPLE POSING
AS FAMILY UNITS,
APPREHENDED, COMPARED TO THE
SAME TIME LAST YEAR.
IN TOTAL, CBT HAS ARRESTED MORE
THAN 268,000 ILLEGALS AT OUR
SOUTHWEST BORDER.
JUST IN THE LAST FIVE MONTHS.
WITH THAT IN PERSPECTIVE, THAT
IS ALMOST THE POPULATION OF
DURHAM, NORTH CAROLINA, WHICH IS
THE 77TH MOST POPULOUS CITY IN
AMERICA.
IF THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO BLOCK
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S NATIONAL
EMERGENCY DECLARATION BECAUSE,
YOU KNOW, THERE IS NO CRISIS AT
THE BORDER.
>> THIS IS A MANUFACTURED
CRISIS.
>> A PROBLEM, NOT A CRISIS.
>> A WALL IS A COLOSSAL WASTE OF
MONEY FOR A CRISIS THAT DOESN'T
EXIST.
>> THIS IS REALLY A MANUFACTURED
CRISIS ON MANY LEVELS.
MANUFACTURED BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Laura: IS NOT MANUFACTURED
UNLESS YOU HAVE OPEN BORDERS,
THEN JUST COME RIGHT IN.
EVEN THE LIBERAL
"NEW YORK TIMES" IS MORE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE PLIGHT OF
THE ILLEGALS THAN THEIR THREAT
TO OUR SAFETY.
JUST LOOK AT THE HEADLINE ON THE
FRONT PAGE TODAY "BORDER
CONTROL'S FACILITIES PUT
DETAINEES WITH MEDICAL
CONDITIONS AT RISK."
WHY IS THE LEFT ATTACKING OUR
BORDER AGENCIES?
THEY ARE PUTTING THEIR LIVES ON
THE LINE TRYING TO PROTECT US,
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
JOINING ME NOW, FOX NEWS MEDIA
ANALYST AND HOST OF "MEDIA
BUZZ," AND TIM BALLARD, FORMER
DHS SPECIAL AGENT AND FOUNDER OF
OPERATION UNDERGROUND RAILROAD,
WHICH RESCUES VICTIMS FROM HUMAN
SMUGGLING.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU ON.
HOW WE, WHY DOES
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," AFTER
LAYING OUT, AND I WANT TO READ
PART OF IT, THEY LAY OUT THIS
HARROWING STORY ABOUT THE BORDE
BORDER.
THEN THEY CLAIM IN AN EDITORIAL
THAT DOESN'T EXIST -- THIS IS
PART OF WHAT THEY WROTE.
"AN AVERAGE OF 2,200 MIGRANTS A
DAY ARE NOW CROSSING THE
1900-MILE BORDER WITH MEXICO,
MANY AFTER GRUELING JOURNEYS
THAT LEAVE THEM INJURED, SICK,
OR BADLY DEHYDRATED, YET MOST OF
THE NATIONS ALONG THE BORDER
LACK SUFFICIENT STAFFING OR
PROCEDURES TO THOROUGHLY ASSESS
HEALTH NEEDS OR TO PROVIDE
MORE THAN BASIC EMERGENCY CARE.
AND THEN COME ON MARCH 5TH COME
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" EDITORIAL
BOARD SAYS THAT NATIONAL
EMERGENCY DOESN'T EXIST.
SAYING "THE NATIONAL EMERGENCIES
ACT DOESN'T DEFINE AN EMERGENCY
IS, A LOOPHOLE TRUMP TOOK
ADVANTAGE OF.
CONTRARY TO ALL OF THE EVIDENCE,
THERE IS BASICALLY NOT A CRISIS
AT THE BORDER."
>> A LEGITIMATE JOURNALISTIC
LOOK AT A HUMANITARIAN CRISIS.
HE SAYS THAT MANY OF THE
MIGRANTS ARRIVE, ALREADY HAVE
CHRONIC DISEASES.
>> Laura: WHY IS THAT THE
AMERICAN TAXPAYERS FOLD?
OUR RESPONSIBILITY?
IT'S HORRIBLE AND IT'S AWFUL AND
PARENTS DO DO THIS, I UNDERSTAND
WHAT THEY'RE DOING IT, BUT THEY
ARE PUTTING THEIR CHILDREN AT
RISK, AND THEMSELVES, AT RISK OF
BEING TRAFFIC THEMSELVES.
>> IT UNDERSCORES HOW MUCH OF
THE MEDIA ARE TOTALLY FOCUSED ON
THE SIDE OF THE STORY.
THIS IS THEIR EMERGENCY, NOT THE
BROADER EMERGENCY --
>> Laura: NOT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND OTHER PEOPLE.
>> ENABLES THEM TO BLAME
EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENS TO
MIGRANTS ON THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Laura: WRITES, AND I'M
TRYING TO GET AT THIS, THEY LAY
OUT WHAT IS IN EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS.
THEY CAN BLAME TRUMP FOR I CAN
SAY IT IS ALL TRUMP'S FAULT, WE
DON'T HAVE A FIVE STAR
FACILITIES AT OUR BORDERS,
HOTELS, FULL CONCIERGE MEDICAL
CARE, ENGLISH LANGUAGE LESSONS.
WE HAVE A LOT OF GOOD STUFF
HELPING PEOPLE, BUT THEY LAY
THIS OUT.
IN THEIR DESCRIPTION, IT IS AN
EMERGENCY, THEY JUST WANT TO
THROW MORE MONEY AT IT.
>> I LOOK AT THIS IN THE EYES OF
KIDS.
I SPENT 12 YEARS ON THAT BORDER,
BY THE WAY, AS AN UNDERCOVER
SPECIAL AGENT LOOKING FOR
CHILDREN BEING TRAFFIC INTO THE
UNITED STATES TO BE SOLD TO OUR
AMERICAN PEDOPHILES.
THERE'S A 300% INCREASE IN
CHILDREN
ADULTS BRING CHILDREN WANT THEIR
KIDS.
93% OF THESE KIDS THAT WE ARE
RECOVERING ARE OUTSIDE THE PORTS
OF ENTRY, SO WHERE ARE THEY
GOING?
A LOT OF THEM ARE BEING USED AS
PAWNS BECAUSE WE HAVE A STRANGE
POLICY THAT CONGRESS PASSED THAT
SAYS BRING A KID AND YOU CAN
CLAIM, YOU KNOW.
>> Laura: DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS, I BLAME BOTH OF
THEM.
IF THEY ARE BOTH RESPONSIBLE,
BOTH PARTIES, FOR NOT ADDRESSING
THIS ASYLUM ISSUE.
AS LONG AS YOU COME IN WITH
SOMEONE YOU SAY IS RELATED TO
YOU, YOU CANNOT BE SENT HOME,
CHILDREN ARE RESETTLED HERE,
EVEN IF THEY ARE TEMPORARILY,
FOR SHORT.
LACK OF TIME SEPARATED, BOTH
SETTLED TOGETHER UNLESS YOU CAN
FIGURE OUT THEY ARE NOT RELATED,
WHERE IS OUR CONGRESS?
TRUMP IS THE PROBLEM?
CRAZY!
>> THINK LIKE A CRIMINAL, RIGHT,
YOU BRING A KID ACROSS, AND IF
YOU'RE CAUGHT, YOU CAN SAY
ASYLUM.
I GET TO STAY HERE.
BUT WE KNOW THEY ARE NOT DOING
ALL OF THEM, THEY ARE TAKING
THESE KIDS AND SELLING THEM INTO
OUR SEX MARKETS HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
WE HAVE TO CONTROL THE MOVEMENT.
A WALL, A BARRIER, CONTROLS AND
MOVEMENT SO CAN IDENTIFY WHO IS
COMING IN.
THROUGH THE EYES OF THE KIDS I
SEE THIS.
SAVE THE KIDS.
>> Laura: THERE IS THE
CHILDREN ASPECT, THE SUFFERING
ASPECT, THE HEALTH ASPECT, AND A
LOT OF PEOPLE WATCHING TONIGHT I
LIKE, LOOK, I SAY THIS, TWO
BLOCKS FROM WHERE WE ARE
BROADCASTING, EVERY NIGHT, WE
DRIVE HOME, AND THERE ARE SEVEN
OR EIGHT PEOPLE ON THE STREET.
IT IS FREEZING OUT TONIGHT.
AS APPEAR TO BE AMERICAN
CITIZENS, AND THEY ARE ON THE
STREETS 500 YARDS FROM THE
NATION'S CAPITAL, AND IT IS SAD,
IT IS HORRIBLE, BUT A LOT OF
AMERICANS WATCH AND THEY GO, WHY
ARE WE PUTTING ALL OF OUR
RESOURCES ON HELPING PEOPLE WHO
NEED TO BE ABLE TO THRIVE IN
THEIR OWN COUNTRY?
AS MUCH AS IT IS SAD.
IT IS SAD TWO BLOCKS FROM HERE.
IT IS THAT WHAT IS HAPPENING
WITH TIM, HE'S DOCUMENTED ALL OF
THIS.
>> PART OF THE WATER SITUATION
THE MEDIA -- AT THE SAME
TIME, DEMOCRATS TRYING TO BLOCK
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S EMERGENCY
DECLARATION.
THERE APPEARS TO BE ENOUGH
REPUBLICAN DEFECTIONS IN THE
SENATE THAT IS GOING TO GO
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
IT WILL BE VETOED, I UNDERSTAND.
>> Laura: IT DOESN'T SURPRISE
ME ONE BIT, WHY DOES IT NOT
SURPRISE ME?
WE ARE GOING BEYOND THE
HEADLINES, YOU DIGGING BEYOND
THE HEADLINES EVERY DAY AND YOU
DO SUCH A GREAT JOB, HOW WE.
THIS IS ABOUT WHAT HAS ALWAYS
HAPPENED WITH THESE TWO PARTIES,
REPUBLICANS LOVE TO HAVE THE
CHEAP LABOR FLOWING IN FOR
BUSINESS FOR THE WORST THING FOR
AMERICAN BUSINESS IS WHEN WE
JUST START GOING UP.
THEY WANT TO KEEP DOWNWARD
PRESSURE ON WAGES.
THE MORE PEOPLE COMING IN, THE
LOWER WAGES CAN BE IN CERTAIN
SECTORS, AND THE DEMOCRATS -- I
WANT TO PLAY THIS FOR
NANCY PELOSI, THIS IS
NANCY PELOSI EIGHT I BELIEVE
TODAY IN AN INTERVIEW.
TELLS WHAT THE DEMOCRATS MOTIVES
ARE.
LET'S WATCH.
>> THESE NEWCOMERS MAKE AMERICA
MORE AMERICAN.
AND WE WANT THEM WHEN THEY COME
HERE TO BE FULLY PART OF OUR
SYSTEM, AND THAT MEANS NOT
SUPPRESSING THE VOTE OF ALL
NEWCOMERS TO AMERICA.
>> Laura: IS SHE TALKING ABOUT
LEGAL IMMIGRANTS, WE WANT
EVERYONE TO BE ABLE TO VOTE, BUT
THIS IS GOING WAY FORWARD.
WE HAVE DEMOCRATS PUSHING TO
LEGALIZE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS TO
VOTE, EVEN IF THEY ARE NOT
CITIZENS, THAT THEY SHOULD BE
ABLE TO VOTE.
THAT IS A NEW MOVEMENT BUILDING
SLOWLY IN LOCALITIES AND CITIES.
THAT IS WHAT THIS IS ABOUT,
VOTES FOR DEMOCRATS, CHEAP
WORKERS WERE REPUBLICANS.
MEANWHILE, KIDS ARE BEING HURT,
AS TIM HAS DOCUMENTED, AND HOW
MUCH MORE MONEY DO YOU HAVE TO
SPEND?
BILLIONS.
>> THE CHALLENGE FOR THE PROCESS
TO FOCUS ON ALL SIDES IF THE
CRISIS AND NOT BE SWEPT AWAY BY
ONE FACTION OF POLITICAL --
>> Laura: I AGREE, BUT WHY NOT
FRONT PAGE ARTICLES IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" OF MORE
ABOUT WHAT IS HAPPENING WITH
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT CRIME IN THE
UNITED STATES?
OH, THEY COMMIT LESS CRIME THAN
AMERICAN-BORN PEOPLE.
THAT IS A TROPE, YOU DON'T HAVE
A BROTHER OR A DAUGHTER OR
SOMEONE WHO HAS BEEN TRAFFIC,
YOU'RE GETTING ENOUGH HELP FROM
CAPITOL HILL IN WHAT YOU ARE
DOING?
YOU GET SOME HELP.
>> WE ARE GETTING HELP FROM THE
UTAH DELEGATION.
THEY HAVE COME STRONG,
SENATOR HATCH, SENATOR LEE,
CONGRESSMAN CURTIS, WE JUST GOT
SOME BILLS PASSED, THE PRESIDENT
SIGNED THEM INTO LAW IN JANUARY.
THE BILLS THAT WILL HELP US WORK
INTERNATIONALLY.
IT'S GOT TO BE A COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH, BECAUSE THESE KIDS ARE
TRAFFIC INTERNATIONALLY.
ALMOST 800,000 A YEAR.
>> Laura: WHAT IS A TYPICAL
MAN, IS THERE AN AGE THAT
ENGAGES IN THIS DISGUSTING,
DESPICABLE CRIMINAL ACTIVITY?
>> THERE IS NO PROFILE.
IT'S SCARY, THEY ARE EDUCATORS,
THEY ARE EVERYBODY.
WE'VE ARRESTED LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS.
YOU CAN'T DETECT THIS, THAT'S
WHY WE HAD TO BE PROACTIVE AS A
NATION TO FIND THESE KIDS.
>> Laura: WE HAVE A 300%
INCREASE OF ADULTS WITH PEOPLE
THEY SAY ARE RELATED TO THEM.
>> AND THEY'RE NOT.
>> Laura: HOW DO WE TRACK THAT
DOWN?
WERE DOING DNA TEST?